[Music]
brock is in lincoln nebraska hi brock
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave and john thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
so i'm 20 years old i'm recently engaged
congratulations beyonce
thank you
me and my fiance are both blessed to
have parents who taught us
financial
wisdom
and we both obviously save and budget
separately since we're not quite married
yet um but my question is
uh we both have um a pretty good chunk
in our savings my mine's been mostly
mutual funds uh hers is just in a
savings account way to go we want to buy
a house
we want to buy a house before
we get married but we don't know how to
do that since our finances aren't
combined yet we don't know if you would
recommend
doing that a month before we're married
or a week or or after the wedding
um so that's kind of my question today
okay
um
well you're probably not gonna like my
answer
uh if i woke up in your shoes knowing
what i know as an old guy
i'm going to tell you to be married a
year
before you close on the house
after you're married a year you will
pick a different house than you will
out of the honeymoon
because you know each other better
the joke we always use is it takes about
a year to know how close to your
mother-in-law to buy
but it's kind of that's kind of you know
we all laugh about that because it takes
a little while to get to know some
things that we think we know prior to
actually living together
uh and being married together and all
that stuff but we really don't know and
you've got plenty of time you're very
wise with your money you can use that
year to pile up money and to study the
real estate market together to dream
together to talk about things together
the things you want in a house the
things you don't care about in a house
the uh whether you want land or you
don't want land uh you know nebraska
right that kind of stuff and so
um you know just just give yourself a
little time here don't be in such a
hurry uh and that one year is going to
cause you to make a much
wiser decision
and um there's a rule in the old
testament
that uh
like for instance under king david when
the armies of israel would go to battle
a man and woman get married the first
year they were married they didn't allow
the men to go to battle
and uh because because they wanted them
to get their marriage set to get knit
because they made a better warrior
than
that right and uh this is kind of in
that same vein yeah i i i could not
agree more take your time man you've got
the rest y'all are so smart and so ahead
of the game
um i'd love y'all to spend a year just
enjoying figuring out what y'all just
did and how you're going to do the rest
of your life together man yeah and it's
just yeah
curtain hanging curtains can cause a
divorce
and so don't do that just don't do that
in the first two weeks of marriage you
know it's like